good morning believe nation today's
message is being yourself over to you
ariana grande be yourself you know and
in your most genuine possible way and
are completely unafraid that's when
everything starts to fall into place and
that takes a while see with so much
public like you know rumors and opinions
on horse you don't I mean it's like yeah
you get scared and you want to hold back
a little but then I was like you know
what like none of this would be
happening if I just show like just was
like good and just was myself and I went
out and I was me silly self and then it
go and it all goes away and then they're
like that's me and it's a life you know
yeah when you let go and you're like
here you go take it or leave it
if you want less it can be like why hold
back you get you can own you one life
just have fun and be yourself and don't
worry about the rest and all falls in a
place you will never do great things if
you hold yourself back the faster you
understand who you are what that looks
like and you have the confidence to
express it that's when great things
start to happen I often get asked in
interviews and questions what would I
give advice to my 20 year old self and
normally I don't have a lot of things to
say because I don't live with regret I'm
really happy where I'm at now and that's
a cumulation of all the things that have
happened in my life but if there was one
thing that I would tell myself going
back is to just believe more to have
more self-confidence to take that idea
that I had and do something with it
and I think we all have these ideas
inside ourselves we have these things
that we want to express these things
we're going to create the song you want
to write the business you want to start
whatever it is you have that thing
inside you and you don't know how to
articulate it well because you've never
done it before because you're afraid you
don't have the skillset you don't have
the connections we've never done it
before this is a lot of nervousness and
so that fear prevents you from getting
started that fear prevents you from
doing it if I look at my youtube channel
when I started it there was profiles of
successful entrepreneurs it was me
answering questions from different
people
entrepreneurs writing in and I was
consistent ish and then when I started
taking it seriously that's when I
started getting better that's when I
started discovering myself that's when I
found my voice and you could learn from
all these other people and model success
on a big fan of it
but at the end of day you have to find
the thing that works for you and that
comes from practicing so when you have
that next thought and when you have that
next idea when you have that next thing
that you want to do don't just sit on it
get tired of sitting on things get tired
of just building up a list of to do is
that never get done I want people to
look at my videos and say that haven't
Carmichael made that we've developed
that style now people will look at it's
not just a logo and it's not just the
top ten rules people will look at a
video and know that this is the style
that I want this is the style that I
made I want you to find that I want you
to stop fitting in I want you to stop
being vanilla I want you to go more
aggressively in on yourself and what you
can do and take those ideas that you
have and start to express them and
understand at the beginning it's not
going to be perfect you're gonna make a
lot of mistakes you won't find your path
yet it may start by copying other people
but as you do it more as you build the
consistency up you will find a unique
path that has never been taken before
and the more you get used to building up
the confidence and courage to follow
that path the bigger that path becomes
and the more success of wheats you at
the end of the road so the question they
today is our curious what is uniquely
you in your business what would people
look at and say that is unique to you
what's your trademark what is the thing
that you bring that's so different I'm
super curious to find out leave it down
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Aviv Oren Aviv thank
you so much you're picking up a copy of
my book your one-word really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you guys
again for watching I hope you have an
amazing day I believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events beso
[Music]
don't become like a cult like don't just
like me be a fan of everyone you can
like Rihanna's music and mine and Gaga's
it's okay you don't have to be like you
know and my mom and dad would never let
me put posters on the wall because they
were like be you be inspired but don't
become anyone else which is why I think
as an artist I wasn't very very the one
thing that I was very proud of us when I
first came out that ever no one compared
me to anyone yeah I think you can tell
when someone's are glad somebody
sometimes and I know I think it's good
to be inspired but don't become somebody
yeah I mean yourself just always be
yourself always whatever people say
about you whatever people believe that
is true that isn't about you trust me
life is not worth living feeling sad and
down and lonely just always be true to
who you are I'm more worried now about
being true to myself and being honest
and you know maybe ten years ago I would
have not done a video like she-wolf but
now it's something I feel like doing you
know so why am I gonna deprive myself
from or deny myself the possibility of
expressing the way I feel I want to
express myself freely I don't I don't
want to be in a golden cage anymore I
don't want to be put behind bars yeah I
think we this life is so brief and and
we spend that sometimes imposing over
ourselves so many limitations and
obstacles that don't allow us to grow as
we would like to you know and and yes
like I feel you know very much like a
woman this time around I I wanted to
show my legs I never showed my legs to
it you know for 20 years
and I always I always did all my
performances with long pants and really
very no I never showed my legs and one
day I looked at them I said hey they're
no bad they're kind of short but they
take me to places I think it
Now or Never you know so I did it it's
about time to really embrace my
individuality and my freedom as I say
won't man as a person and that's a
message that I encourage to other women
and that doesn't mean necessarily
letting yourself being objectified
because that means satisfying the
desires of other people you know I say
satisfy your own desires you know I live
your life to the fullest because it's
short I'm not pretending to be something
that I'm not or pretending to be this
goody two-shoes or whatever I'm just
being myself and and I think that you
know then nobody can be disappointed and
Who I am as a person or I don't feel
like I have to hide or pretend because
I'm not I'm not I'm just being there you
know and I'm just going through life and
learning out you know learning how to be
a young woman and it just you know and I
have that responsibility and I think
it's a responsibility is it is it a
little bit of a weight sometimes
absolutely but it's it's responsibly